the wife of Olympic gold medal skier
Bode Miller is opening up about the
recent death of their little daughter
Emmeline the 19 month old girl drowned
in a neighbor's pool last month Motors
wife Morgan said yesterday the drowning
is a silent killer in younger children
and it needs more attention she's
supporting the water safety campaign of
another mom whose son drowned the same
day as little Emmeline Dana Jacobson is
here with the story of this bond formed
out of tragedy Dana good morning this is
heartbreaking story happens far too long
it does if some good can come of it
that's what both these mothers are
hoping bode miller and morgan beck said
they were beyond devastated when their
toddler who maim called emmy drowned on
June 10th that's actually the same day
that Nicole Hughes lost her
three-year-old son in a similar drowning
accident now the two mothers want to
educate people on how fast children
between 1:00 and 4:00 can drown a
problem they say is misunderstood and
rarely discussed every picture I had of
him from that last day he is wearing a
life jacket or a puddle jumper
it only took seconds for Nicole Hughes
to lose track of her three-year-old son
Levi he's eating M&Ms and a beach chair
he's in a life jacket I mean I took
water safety very seriously after a day
at the beach the Hughes family went back
to their rental home which also had a
pool showered and had dinner Nicole and
Levi split a brownie for dessert as they
waited for the Sun to set I walked out
back on the balcony when I looked over
the second floor had somehow gotten out
a heavy door down a flight of stairs and
was facedown in the deep end Hughes and
her husband who's a doctor began CPR
right away but it wasn't enough
Levi died at the hospital I don't know
why no one is talking about the drowning
that is taking place when kids aren't
even swimming when it's a non swim time
the Hughes had no idea that on the same
day another family was going through the
same tragedy skier Bodhi Miller's wife
Morgan Beck and their 19 month old
daughter Emmie were at a neighbor's
house when the toddler somehow fell into
a pool and drowned on Instagram
yesterday Beck posted a picture of Emmy
with the words I pray to God no other
parent feels this pain she also tagged
Nicole writing my heart is with you I
know that so many different families
that I suppose
and with you know including the Millers
and we just all know how unfortunately
now we have this shared heartache 69
percent of children who drown are not
actively swimming and aside from birth
defects drowning is the leading cause of
death in children ages 1 to 4 we were
told that a child can drown in less than
one minute they sink to the bottom and
they immediately gasp and start crying
and all the water immediately gets in
their lungs and there's there's no
oxygen three-year-olds don't know to
hold their breath they don't know to
struggle the real truth about drowning
that it is silent that it is quick that
it happens when you're not expecting it
the Hughes family has started a
foundation in their sons on or Levi's
legacy and is calling on the American
Academy of Pediatrics to urge
pediatricians to educate parents about
the unique risks for drowning and
toddlers the AAP says parents should
never even for a moment leave children
alone near open bodies of water they
have not yet responded directly to the
family's call for action John I
mentioned this to you for Nicole it was
so quick she said that brownie she had
eaten with her son was still in her
mouth when they found him that's how
fast this happened this is what it
surprises me I didn't realize it could
be that fast it shows you that even the
most vigilant parent it can happen
because I always thought take a couple
minutes at least but a minute no parent
is watching every single second of what
their child is this Trench don't you
have to do that and the strength that it
takes to turn a tragedy and it's
something positive like these parents
are doing if they can save one guy right
one child they will stay in it thank you
we'll do that